I see myself as part of a movement for
social change so when I think about what
to write and thinking about what would
be useful and I'm thinking about what
what arguments would be mobilizing at a
particular point yeah and so maybe it's
a little bit of a different way of
thinking about about journalism the sort
of question of you know what would be
what would be useful as opposed to just
what interests me what am i curious
about it this given day I do ask myself
that question and in terms of philosophy
you know I think at this point in
history just believing that every life
is of equal value is it is enough to two
separate you know and define a mission
at this point because I think I think we
really are up against a lot of people
who just do not think that lives are of
equal value I mean even if you look at
something like casualty statistics in
Iraq the idea that it's somehow
acceptable not to keep track of how many
Iraqis have died right and what that
says to the Iraqi people to the Arab and
Muslim world just the extraordinary
racism in that idea you know that the
reporting of only American deaths and
that we don't do body counts whether in
Afghanistan or Iraq so you know just
just believing that every life is an
equal value regardless of where you live
or what skin color you are seems to be a
radical idea these days
you